- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website, or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked large-brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Pascal] Thanks very much for this great
afternoon, to all the speakers. I'm
especially grateful to Dan Lieberman for
having set the stage with a lot of carnage
and meat-eating, because the molecules I
talk about today have to do with
vertebrates and what we eat and what
happens to it in our bodies. So this
afternoon I'd like to share an idea about
a way that a molecule could be driving
speciation and share some evidence for it
in Vigo [sp], not in primates but in mice.
I like to start with by acknowledging the
people who've done some of the heavy
lifting, including Fang Ma who's back in
Chengdu, a former lab member and Darius
Ghaderi and my team here especially Stevan
Springer and Miriam Cohen, as well as my
collaborators, Ajit Varki and his team.
The kelp there in the background is
actually an analogy I use when I talk
about the glycocalyx. Every living life,
every living cell has a sugar coat called
glycocalyx which consist of glycolipids
and glycoprotiens that completely cover
the cell and give it its molecular
identity. These molecules swing around
very much like the kelp in the ocean right
here. And if we make ourselves hundreds of
millions of times smaller and land on a
cell, one of my favorite cells, a
mammalian sperm cell, we would see
something that reminds us of one of these
kelp forests. These are the glycolipids
and glycoproteins. All of them share short
sugar chains on them, each little sugar is
about one nanometer big. And what they
share is that most of these chains
terminate in a sugar coat sialic acid that
helps define the identity of the cell type
and it tells the body that this is a self
cell. So sialic acid can be thought of as
a very potent self signal. You can
visualize them here with an antibody and
you see the entire surface of the sperm,
it's payload so to speak is the haploid
genome in blue. And the surface of the
sperm is completely covered in sialic
acids. To go back to the kelp analogy,
macrocystis kelp has these big terminal
bulbs that help it float and it defines
the outer edge, the molecular frontier of
every cell, that's what you can think of
as sialic acids. They're very important
because they're telling the body that this
is self and they play a role in
fertilization, in gestation, in
development including during pregnancy.
Peter Medawar many years ago coined the
phrase "immunological paradox of mammalian
pregnancy" where a female, a mother, is
gestating an individual that is
genetically not identical to her within
her body, in a very intimate contact. The
interface between the fetal cells of the
trophoblast and the mother includes these
sialic acids, these sugar molecules found
on cell surfaces of all vertebrates. This
matters, it can be quite dramatic. This
young fellow here was born in 1963 and he
had a problem; his mother was type O, had
a lot of antibodies against type A blood.
And they had a former son and his father
was type A. So what happened during the
pregnancy is that the antibodies that his
mother were making passed through the
placenta and almost killed him. He was
born with massive hemolytic disease of the
newborn that had only been described a
couple of years earlier. And it's only
because he was given two complete blood
transfusions that he can stand here today
and give a talk. So sugars and mismatches
of sugars are really important. But I
would like to propose that there is
another immunological paradox and it's the
one about mammalian fertilization. How do
sperm manage to survive this journey from
insemination to the place of fertilization
way up in the ampulla of the oviduct? If
you think back, when you were a sperm, the
reproductive tract of your mother was
about the equivalent of six kilometers,
we're back to running. Of course, hundreds
of millions of potential you's were
inseminated, but only one made it up all
the way to the ampulla. And that is partly
due to a massive influx of immune cells of
the mother upon insemination that take out
and actively kill, potentially select,
most of the sperm. Only a few hundreds
make it to the oviduct where they
capacitate, they start sprinting,
galloping and one of them meets the egg
and fertilizes it. So, females may be
scrutinizing and even selecting sperm. Why
would they do that? Well, one thing they
might have to look out for is, is it the
correct species? Male mammals are quite
famous for trying to mate with anything
that is shaped roughly like that. But the
female might be interested in some read
out of the fitness of the male who made
the sperm or in the fact that the male is
genetically compatible also more
importantly that the sperm is still
functional. Wasting one precious egg on a
sperm that already lost its acrosome and
is not fit to make a surviving embryo
would be a terrible waste. So, I come back
to the sialic acid on the surface of cells
and in most mammals, the two most common
sialic acids are called N-acetylneuraminic
acid and N-glycolylneuraminic acid, AC and
GC for short. What is interesting is that
there's an enzyme the modifies AC to GC
and humans are natural knock outs. This is
work by Ajit Varki's laboratory that over
the last 15 years has found the mechanism.
We are knock out for a gene that was an
insertion of a selfish piece of DNA that
destroyed the gene. We cannot make the GC
anymore. All of us in this room are pure
AC on our cell surfaces. So the cell
surface of a human differs dramatically
from that of most other mammals. So with
all our close living ape relatives, we
share AC. But because of a mutation that
is quite well-timed with three different
methods using coalescence, molecular clock
and the type of element that is present,
we know that this mutation happened
between 2 and 3 million years ago. And we
know that it causes us to only have one
type of sugar on our cell surface, of
sialic acid. Now you'd think it's a tiny,
tiny change in DNA, why could this be a
big deal? I haven't mentioned that your
average cell has tens to hundreds of
millions of this molecule. So a tiny
change in your DNA changes the flavor, the
molecular flavor of your cells in a big
way. A human cell would appear in one
flavor and a non-human cell in a
completely different flavor. What could
have driven this? You're looking at a
model of a cell surface of a red blood
cell which make up over 80% of all your
cells. And they're targeted by some of the
most important pathogens that we know for
human kind such as falciparum, malaria.
This molecule encircled is glycophorin A
that carries a lot of sialic acid which
malaria uses to get into the host. So a
couple of years back with Ajit, we
commented on the fact that it is known
that the apes that still make most of our
great ape cousins sick, they use sialic
acid that we don't have anymore. They
cannot infect us. So, one possible driving
force for the loss of this sugar initially
might have been to escape a pathogen such
as an ancestral malaria. We got a nice
break. Unfortunately, much, much later in
the Neolithic with agriculture and the
expansion of Anopheles mosquito species,
malaria caught up with us with a vengeance
and is now highly specific for the sugar
we have on human cells. Now,
interestingly, as we've heard somewhere
along the line to Homo, we became top
predators and we regularly engage in
hunting or scavenging or a combination of
both. And when you eat this non-human
sugar, you actually incorporate it and you
start making an immune reaction to it. So
after having lost the sugar, we started
getting regularly immunized to it and
making antibodies. And there is ongoing
work showing that this is incorporated, is
relevant for modern Homo sapiens, all of
us who eat red meat which is the biggest
source of this non-human sugar, continue
to immunize ourselves and to incorporate
it. So several years back, we asked,
"Well, could it be that if sperm differs
so dramatically that a change in cell
surface sugars could actually have been
involved in this reproductive
incompatibility that I was unlucky enough
to suffer from when I was born? That was
ABO blood groups, very unusual, a rare
case. But this would have been a very
powerful point, a way to immunize the
mother against the sugar she doesn't have.
Could this have been involved, this
mutation? The fixation of it, could that
have been driven? Could that have driven
the speciation along the lineage to modern
Homo? So one thing we could do at the time
is obtain chimpanzee sperm in a
non-invasive fashion. I shall not go into
details. And expose those chimpanzee sperm
to human serum with antibodies and show
that they die. But the reverse is not
true. We could also show that compliment
gets deposited on sperm. It seems to be an
antibody-driven killing mechanism in human
serum. Luckily by then, there was a model
mouse that carried the same mutation that
we humans carry. You can see that the
wild-type mouse has the non-human sialic
acid on its sperm, the knock out mouse
doesn't. And so we said, "Well, let's use
these mice to prove whether this mechanism
could function." And we could show that
yes, the immunized mice would make
antibodies that stick to the sperm. The
two groups of females, we mated with
different males, had similar comparable
levels. And there were antibodies very
importantly in the female reproductive
tract of these mice. So, that would be a
way to model female immunity being hostile
to the ancestral molecule. And after
hundreds of mating experiments,
effectively the only group of pairings
where there was a 30% reduction in
fertility was with females lacking a
sugar, making antibodies against a sugar
that was on sperm that was mismatched.
Now, 30% reduction in fertility, is that
important? Could that drive speciation?
And this is where Stevan Springer came in
and came up with an instantaneous model of
selection with pay-off matrices of all
possible combination between the genotypes
of males and females. Interestingly, this
process could not start by sexual
selection. This is a type of sexual
selection, female immunity, punishing
sperm for carrying the wrong sugar. But if
a pathogen were to introduce and favor the
mutation, very quickly as the frequency of
the mutation rises in the females, males
get rewarded by also losing the sugar
because they gain compatibility. And after
a certain moment, you can cross a
threshold from negative selection in
females, in pink, to a net positive
selection in black. In males, as soon as
there is enough females that lack the
sugar, it is worth losing the sugar. So
that should gain compatibility. We modeled
the effect of both the degree of
incompatibility and promiscuity and it
showed that with a promiscuity of about
three matings per ovulation. So a female
would have to mate between two and five
males for each egg. And a frequency of
only about 0.4% which is 1 in 25 females
will be homozygous. This process would
become a directional selection fixing the
allele. So in a cartoon version, the idea
is that pathogens are prominently driving
the sugars on your cell surfaces, that's
why we have blood groups. But usually
these changes go back and forth. And they
generate selection that oscillates and
results in polymorphisms that do not fix.
But if this process comes on the sexual
selection via female antibodies against
molecules on the sperm, you have
directional selection that rapidly fixes
the loss of functional mutation. So what
we propose might have happened somewhere
in the past and possibly at the beginning
of the genus Homo is a very important
pathogen driving changes in the glycocalyx
of the host. Some of the hosts would have
been homozygous. They would have looked
very different. The females by virtue of
their new mode of life with much hunting
and contact with other animal products
would have been immunized against this
sugar. That immunity also protected them
from infection from these bugs, but it
would preclude optimal compatibility with
males that still had the ancestral
molecule, eventually driving apart two
populations even within the same sympatric
environment. So as a model for sympatric
speciation of ancestral hominids. The hope
now is to get fossil material to actually
look for incorporated monosaccharides as
far back as 3 or 4 million years and find
out which lineages still have both sugars
as opposed to which lineages already had
just one sugar and would make a better
candidate for our ancestors.
Thank you very much.
♪ [music] ♪